uh hi there steve kaufman here um
hopefully i have my volume uh adjusted
better today so that uh
that the sound quality will be better
than the last video
um
i was asked to do a video in french i
think i'll do one i should do
some more videos in different languages
but today though i want to focus on
language strategies
because i want to continue talking a bit
about the strategy that i had five days
to fluency in check
uh you will see that i've put up a video
where which i've extracted from a
conversation that i had with a czech
tutor
i'm going to try to speak check once or
twice a week so that i don't lose it
i went more than a month after leaving
prague without speaking check which
didn't help
i'm also going to try to speak once or
twice a week in russian so i don't mess
up my russian and i also continue
listening and reading
to
uh czech and russian
but i wanted to talk about overall
strategy so i had a strategy i called it
five days to fluency
i put most of my effort into passive
learning so to speak in other words
listening and reading and building up my
ability to understand building up my
vocabulary and then in a final spurt
with a couple of months to go i stepped
up by speaking got it up to about five
hours a week and then while in prague
spoke seven or eight hours a day
and yet i didn't become fluent
i didn't become fluent because i don't
speak smoothly i i and as i watch myself
in the video that you'll see
uh or you may have seen
i i hear the mistakes that i'm making i
and these are mistakes that that i mean
i feel if i lived there for three months
i think with the solid base that i have
in my vocabulary and my ability to
understand
i could become fluent but in five days i
can't become fluent with all due respect
to dr juliganov who suggested that i
could activate my passive vocabulary in
five days that's not the case because
fluency requires it's it's uh like
governing as they say in russian you
speak freely you speak without effort
don't speak effortlessly
so it i think in order to be able to
speak effortlessly freely
you have to speak a lot
now so what's the strategy some people
have the strategy of wanting to speak
from the beginning
and uh so then they're um put their you
know emphasis and focus on speaking
and uh and that's one strategy but it's
not my strategy i'm sticking with my
strategy and my strategy is to put the
the emphasis on
getting to where you can understand the
language
and building up your vocabulary and once
you have that base then it becomes quite
easy in my view to
learn to speak fluently but you still
have to speak a lot then once you have
this arsenal of words once you
understand what's happening then you got
to work on speaking now i often hear
people hear
say immigrants especially because i have
a lot of contact with the chinese
immigrant community they'll say ah yes
but we chinese we read well
uh
but we can't speak well
so then i say well how many of you have
read a novel do you read for pleasure do
you read
and of course many most of them don't
i remember meeting a couple a swedish
couple friends of mine we were in france
and then this couple they're both great
francophiles they like going to france
and they speak french quite well
it's or so it appears and so i gave them
a gift of an audiobook of french
literature they couldn't understand the
audiobook
so
i don't know i feel personally my
strategy i mean their french is good
enough in a restaurant
but if they were to get involved in a
serious discussion with someone they
wouldn't understand very well they have
trouble understanding movies they have
trouble understanding audiobooks they
probably don't read a lot in french for
pleasure
but
their approach their knowledge of french
serves their purpose
uh but it's not what i would choose to
do
i would rather have
a sufficient vocabulary so that i can
read books
books of interest
and so that i can understand what i hear
i can listen now to
czech radio i can listen to ekamuski i
can read books i can watch movies
and enjoy it
and even though i don't speak very well
i know that if i were put in a situation
where i had to speak i would improve
quite quickly and i saw it in prague my
speaking ability improved although i
didn't become fluent and the same when i
visited russia and saying petersburg and
moscow my russian improved and then of
course it fell off but the base is there
so that if i go back and once again i'm
in a situation where i have to speak a
lot i can very quickly you know improve
and each time i do that i get better and
better uh so but why what should be you
know for most people what should be the
strategy well it depends again on what
people want to do but i have a very good
friend who's 83 and he's been studying
spanish
and i guess his spoken spanish isn't
great
but he can read latin american
literature
and uh
i mean he lives in vancouver how many
days of the year does he speak spanish
not very often however he derives a
great deal of pleasure from being able
to read in spanish so to me
the amount of time and effort that we
put into
developing this what seems to be a
passive capability in the language is by
no means time wasted because
developing those passive abilities
gives us
something that we can actually use when
we live away from the language we can
watch movies and enjoy them we can
listen to radio by the internet we can
read and we can enjoy the language and
in doing that we are always getting
better
but if you put all of your emphasis on
being on being able to speak right away
and you don't build up this solid base
in terms of comprehension skills and in
terms of vocabulary then while you may
be able to speak what you'll be able to
say and what you will understand
uh you know coming back from native
speakers will be quite limited and so
then you have to have to ask yourself uh
you know am i in a situation where i
need to speak spanish a lot
um you know if it's just for the two
weeks that you go to mexico
then yeah you're probably quite happy
with having a very um superficial
capability in the language
however
yeah i guess the strategy comes back to
what your goals are
to me that's not a satisfactory goal
you know to be able to say that you
speak the language it's not sufficient
to be able to
trot off a few phrases
to be able to speak the language i think
you have to be able to engage with
people speak freely which i don't yet do
in in czech and i don't really think i
do it in russian either
uh but you have to be able to understand
and so i would be quite comfortable and
and the same is true with my portuguese
i never speak portuguese i speak
portuguese very poorly but i understand
so if someone at link as
recently
as diego
member link sent me a a one hour
wonderful tv program video
on the brazilian economy so i can watch
this and i can understand it all and i
enjoy it
so these are ways in which i can enjoy
my my portuguese here now if i went out
and had an evening with a bunch of
brazilians here locally or with some
russians or with some checks i would
have a very good under uh you know
chance of understanding what they're
talking about and i can chime in and
i'll get better as the evening wears on
or what usually happens is you get
better and then you get worse you get
better at first you're sort of carried
on by some kind of adrenaline adrenaline
and then all of a sudden fatigue sets in
and you start to have more difficulty uh
but if i were all of a sudden
uh
to live for a month or two in brazil a
month or two in czech republic a month
or two in russia i know i'm totally
confident that i would become
genuinely fluent in the language so what
where i prefer to invest my time is
again in building up my comprehension
building up my um vocabulary and
enjoying the language immensely and this
is one of the dilemmas right now i want
to start into korean
uh and and it's it's it's so difficult
to tear myself away
from the languages that i'm enjoying
where i can actually engage with
meaningful and interesting content
and i've got to go back to korea now
where i'm dealing with uh
relatively uninteresting beginner
content and i have to you know try to
build up my
my comprehension in korean to where i
can actually get at things that are
interesting
and that's sort of the difficult period
and it's difficult to tear yourself away
from
the
existing relationships that you have
with each other with these other
languages so again speaking of strategy
i'm going to focus on the
you know who is she and
eating out those two simple uh stories
we have at link and i'm going to listen
to them over and over and over again
along with some other material that i've
found
where it's basic and simple i listen
over and over and over again
until i get enough of a
toe hold that i can start attacking
you know authentic material and i think
it'll take me six months to get to where
i can understand you know adult material
uh comfortably
uh and then uh yeah as a part of my
strategy i hope to go to korea and spend
uh a week or two
which will
you know propel me forward plus it'll
also be a goal that'll help keeping keep
me on track
but i don't think
realistically that i'll end up being a
fluent speaker of korean after just a
week or so there so just to update you
on five days to fluency the experiment
and what i consider to be
the language learning strategy that
works for me now it may be different for
other people it undoubtedly is thanks
for listening bye for now